I will be the first to admit
I have trouble sometimes in conversation
when the other person gets emotional.
That's That's me being honest and
transparent with you.
If somebody is getting really emotional,
whether it's anger, meaning they
escalate in anger, or maybe they're
really sad and they're crying a whole
lot, or maybe they feel really closed
off, or they're having big emotions,
that's hard for me to process sometimes.
Throughout this episode, I want you to
see the conversation between me and you,
or you and another person,
as you two in a circle, in a enclosed,
confined space. But let's give it some
room. Let's not be claustrophobic. Give
yourselves some some space.
That it's this preserved bubble that
you're in, that is a circle. And whether
or not how much space you have in this
conversation for emotion. Like I said,
sometimes I have a hard time with that.
I tend to be um somebody who can
sometimes see emotions as a distraction
to the point or the goal or the finish
line of what I'm wanting to communicate.
And sometimes that's good. As an
attorney, that's how we're taught. All
right, I can have clients that are very
emotional right in front of me, and it
won't affect me at all. And there's
sometimes that, yeah, I get pulled on my
heartstrings, and I I want to help, and
I'm there. And there are other times
where it is it's just part of the
process because I've seen a lot of
emotion. People come to me, and a lot of
trial attorneys can relate to this. I
They're seeing I'm seeing them at some
of the lowest, hardest points of their
life. And so, it's also a sign of
strength for me to say, I can take on
your emotion.
I can be here with you. I And at the
same time, I can still be empathetic
without trying to make you feel worse or
make it feel like you shouldn't feel
this way. So, there's some part of it
where emotion's just part of the game. I
can Or I'm I I be deposing a witness,
uh asking questions and they start to
cry.
That's that's part of it. So sometimes I
have to see through that emotion.
That's professionally. In relationship
side,
that's just part of the the life. That's
part of the relationship is to be
vulnerable with those emotions of how
you're feeling and I I'm definitely not
going to talk to a witness when they're
going through some time of emotion, I'm
going to talk with my wife or my mom or
my dad or my siblings or my kids. So,
it's
it's understanding context, it's
understanding environment. So, let's
call that the the bubble in this. So,
admittedly, sometimes I have trouble
with that. That's just me being honest.
And there are other times where despite
me having difficulty sometime, I can
tell you how to control
your own self in the conversation even
when they get emotional. And I don't do
this I'm not telling you this in some
kind of hidden trick way or there's some
kind of Jedi mind trick. There's not.
There's just very simple key things I
want you to keep in mind when somebody
else
on the other side is trying to get
emotional. So, I want you to kind of nod
your head right now if that's you. You
feel like when other people get
emotional in the conversation,
you don't know how to process that.
Maybe you get you tense up, maybe you
freeze, maybe you want to distance
yourself from it. You're not really sure
how to do it and you're you feel awkward
all of a sudden. I want to reassure you
that's totally normal, all right? I can
I can relate to that to some extent. So,
I want to help you through this in this
episode. So, here we go. You ready?
Number one, what I want you to do when
it comes to maintaining control when the
other person gets emotional is to
understand first before you start even
assessing the other person,
understand your own physical cues.
And I mean physical.
So, understand how in that moment their
emotions affect your physical.
Meaning, do you find that your face
crunches up?
Like I'm doing right now. Do you find
that your body or your neck tenses up?
Regardless of the emotion that they're
showing, let's let's not go into the
details yet. Let's Let's keep it surface
and then we'll go deep.
What happens when you perceive any kind
of emotion?
Cuz most of the time, whether it's happy
or sad, we still have a physical
reaction to it from whatever emotion
that they're showing. So, maybe you
scoot away. Maybe your head looks away
cuz you don't want to face it. Maybe you
feel like you
Maybe you
clench your fists. I was thinking of the
word. I didn't know the forgot the word.
You clench your fists in some extent. We
all have a physical reaction, and your
job right now is to think of yours. Just
5 seconds.
What tends to be your first gut reaction
when somebody on the other side of you
gets emotional? For me,
I find that often
it's difficult for me to keep eye
contact with them because I don't want
them to feel that they're
on the witness stand or they are on this
pedestal or they are
all eyes are on them. And sometimes eye
contact makes it harder on the other
person. So, maybe I might avoid my eyes.
Sometimes I can shut down. In other
words, I'm going to distance myself a
little bit because I don't want to be
maybe too strong in the conversation. Um
so, that tends to be sometimes that that
happens. Someone gets really, really
emotional in the conversation. And it
also depends, which I'm hearing you say
right now, is Jefferson, it depends on
what kind of emotion they're showing.
And I I understand that. If it's sadness
and the other person is very sad, and
let's say they're crying a whole lot,
you know, I don't know really how to
deal with that. What I can tell you is
that it's not helpful if you try to
avoid it and distance. Why? Because it
makes them feel all the more isolated.
Instead, you have to get comfortable
with understanding your physical cues
and being comfortable around what
they're doing in that sadness. That
shows empathy, that shows sympathy.
That shows that their emotions aren't
scaring you off.
If it's anger that they're showing,
different story because what happens, we
typically hold our breath
and then we start to prepare to run, to
yell, to fight back. We're just to fight
or flight fully on board. We don't know
if we want to throw hurtful words,
escalate the behavior. So, what is the
main key that drives this?
Is your physical cues.
Your body will almost always betray you
in that way.
You ever heard when somebody goes,
"What's You seem like you're mad." And
you're like, "I don't know.
I'm not mad." And like, "Okay, well,
your Your face and your voice say you
do." It's because your body knows.
Regardless of what you say in your mind,
your body knows.
And sometimes it will betray you that
way.
In ways that you're not expecting. So,
number one, understand your physical
cues. If you don't know naturally what
you do when you're feeling the emotions
of somebody else,
ask a friend.
Ask your closest friend, a partner, a
spouse, a parent. Say, "Hey, when things
get emotional, what do you see that I I
tend to do?" Ask them that question and
I promise you'll learn something.
It's It's going to help you. Why Why do
you want to know your physical cues?
Because that is step one.
If you cannot control your physical
cues, if you do not know what's
happening to your body in that moment,
then I cannot help you. Then nobody can
help you. Then you will not have control
when the other person gets emotional. If
you cannot at least acknowledge and
identify what your physical cues are.
Cool? Okay, number two. I want you to
start using phrases in your head that
ground you.
That sounds woo-woo. It's not. I promise
it's not. I do it and I I'm not a
woo-woo fan. So,
what does that mean? Use phrases in your
head to ground yourself. We're going to
talk to our self and use phrases when
the other person's getting emotional
that help us stay in the moment. When I
say present, I mean my mind is not off
somewhere else. I'm here. I'm focused in
on what is happening in front of me. I'm
not in the past. I'm not in the future.
I am right here in this moment. There is
no other point in time that will ever be
the same as when I am listening to you
right now. And I might need to use
phrases that I'm going to say to myself
that you and I are going to work out
together that's that are going to be
personal to you that are going to help
you
make sure and realize that your feet are
planted. So, wherever you are right now,
if you're listening, maybe you're
standing, maybe you're walking, maybe
you're in your car, I want you just like
wiggle your toes. Remember the those
guys?
Yeah, you maybe you forgot that they
were there. Wiggle them for a second.
Okay, cool. Now, just keep them still.
That's I I want to just put this image
of grounding. So, just push your feet if
you can into the ground. The soles of
your feet of your shoes, your socks,
feel it in the ground. That is you
planted in that moment. So, what we're
going to do, we're going to use phrases
that help you. And I'm going to share
with you two of mine. All right? Number
one, when somebody's getting emotional,
what I say to myself is the same thing
that I say if I find that I'm getting
defensive. Because often, if there's
anger in front of me, that emotion, I
want to pick it up.
So, what do I ground myself with? I use
the phrase put it down, Jefferson.
I I'm not kidding. I immediately would
go put it down, Jefferson. Put it down.
Put it down. I I think of my my son
kicking something off the ground and I'm
like, "Ah, let let go of that. You don't
need to be picking up this
I don't know. It could be whatever kids
pick up that is best that they not." So,
you name it. Or I just go in my head,
"Put it down, Jefferson. That's not
yours to carry. That's not yours to pick
up. It is not yours. It is their
emotion.
Don't pick it up. You can see it. You
can acknowledge it.
I said, "Put it down, Jefferson." So,
right now, just say it to yourself,
whatever your name is,
"Put it down."
See how that feels to you. You're going
to come up maybe with your own personal
phrase that feels good to you to remind
you to drop it.
Drop it. Don't take on their emotion.
You are here in the present, grounded,
without trying to add anything else to
it. Another that I like, another that I
like, is I will say to myself, "There is
space for this."
"There is space for this."
Meaning if I'm in a conversation with
somebody who's starting to get
emotional, whether it's sadness or
anger,
I ground myself with the phrase, "There
is space for this." Meaning two things
can be true at the same time.
I can have my emotions, and they can
have their emotions, and two things can
be true at the same time.
Both emotions can be true. Doesn't mean
either one is right. Doesn't mean either
one is less valid than the other. Two
things can be true at the same time.
There is space for both of this.
So, maybe I'm mad, right? And maybe my
wife is really sad.
Or vice versa. It doesn't It doesn't
mean that either one of us
is on a bad playing field. It It It
means that there is space for both of
this. Or maybe I am having a
conversation with um an attorney
who's really grinding my gears.
And this attorney's getting heated.
Well, I know that's coming from a
purpose and a reason. I'm not going to
let that control me. For me to control
myself and control the conversation even
when they start to get emotional is to
remind myself there's space for this.
There's enough room. So, that goes back
to the circle that we talked about, this
bubble.
So, if there's space for it, we're going
to widen that enough, the circle between
me and you right now, there's enough
space. If there's not, then we have to
widen our circle. That means if there's
not enough space it means that bubble
doesn't include both of us, it it only
includes me.
And if that's the case, then that's the
conversation you
we're going to have to rethink from the
very beginning because that's a
conversation you don't really want to be
in and that's a conversation that the
other person doesn't deserve you in.
So, because that's that's that's not a
two-way connection, you feel me? So,
when you are both in the bubble,
the circle of communicating,
it's okay for you to ground yourself,
make sure you have control,
to say, "There is space for this."
That's Those are two of my favorites.
Now, you can make any
phrase that you want. It's totally up to
you.
Totally up to you. A phrase that's going
to ground you.
There is no right answer, there is no
wrong answer.
It is simply a reminder of I am here,
this emotion is valid, or this emotion I
see, this this emotion I observe,
rather than taking it and knitting it
into a sweater and then putting it on
deciding that that's now your emotion,
too, and you're going to get worked up
about it. All right? That's how to
continue to maintain control even when
they get emotional.
I want to take a moment to tell you
about Timeline. When we talk about aging
well, we usually like to talk about
um our diet, our exercise, the cold
plunge, whatever it is, but there's
actually something that needs to go down
at the cellular level. That's right.
We're talking the mitochondria. You
remember the mitochondria, the
powerhouse of the cell? Well, it turns
out that you actually need that energy.
And what Timeline does, all right,
through a supplement called Mitopure,
which I've been taking now and it tastes
delicious. Um
They're like these little gummies that
are awesome. Like seriously, they do
taste good. That
help clear out bad, damaged
mitochondria, so that it restores and
gives you clean mitochondria for better
cellular health. Timeline has spent over
15 years researching mitochondrial
health and in human clinical studies,
people saw improvements in muscle
strength and energy without changing
their routine. For me, it's about
staying sharp, staying strong, and
making sure that I am having as much
energy in my body as I possibly can. And
where does that start? The powerhouse of
the cell. I promise you they really do
taste delicious. So, Timeline's
clinically proven formula is now
available at a new lower price. Mitopure
now starts at $79 when you go to
timelife.com/jefferson.
Go to timelife.com/jefferson.
And now, let's keep going.
Number three, what I want you to stand
in line with here is that
even when they get emotional, there's a
boundary.
There is a boundary.
That is a boundary that protects you.
In they don't really have to do
anything. So, that means if they're
starting to raise their voice, this
really goes for things that are
negative. In other words, it's anger,
it's rage, it's frustration, irritation
that they're trying to put on you.
They're They're trying to color you in
those emotions.
When that kind of thing happens, you put
up a boundary with that.
What I mean is, first off, we're not
going to mirror what you see. If they
start to get angry, we're not going to
mirror that. If they start to raise
their voice
and and their level is uh level six,
that doesn't mean you're going to see it
as a competition or raise it to level
eight. That's not maintaining control,
that is simply giving away your control.
That means the louder they get, the more
steady your voice will be. That means
the faster they go, the slower your
voice is going to sound. And I promise
you, you will always sound more in
control of that conversation than the
other person. What happens is they're
going to eventually regulate to come
back down. So, how do you maintain that
that boundary? Here's some phrases that
I like. One is I I set up this framework
that
I do not X
Y Z.
If you continue to X Y and Z, then this
is the end of the conversation for me.
For example,
I don't respond to somebody who's
yelling at me.
If you continue to yell and raise your
voice,
this is the end of the conversation.
Simple as that. Simple boundary.
Now, it's it's If they want to continue
to talk, now they know the rules of the
game, the rules of play.
I don't respond to disrespect. If you
continue to talk with me in that tone,
this is the end of the conversation for
me.
That's still a boundary.
Every bit of a boundary.
You can still be there for their
emotions. You still can be there to
observe them,
but also maintain your own sense of
self-worth and self-respect, making sure
that that doesn't get diluted or watered
down.
Another that I really like is I'm
willing to talk, not be talked over.
I'm willing to talk
and I'm not willing to talk like this.
That's one of my favorites.
Because I'm I'm What I'm doing is I'm
using and, not but.
This is how my my weird brain goes. So,
if I say,
I'm willing to talk,
but not like this,
that but deletes I'm willing to talk.
I think it's stronger my
professional opinion of I'm willing to
talk
and I'm not willing to talk like this.
So, it it's very clear
of what I'm willing to do and what I'm
not willing to do.
And you can shorten it however you like.
I'm not trying to be super nitpicky.
It's It's going to be whatever is right
for you. Maybe you want to say, "I'm not
comfortable continuing to talk like
this.
If we continue to talk this way,
I I'm going to need a break.
I'm going to need a time out."
Those are boundaries to protect you. So,
even when they start to get overly
emotional, that is you maintaining
control in the conversation. They're
short, they're simple, they are there to
help you.
And if the other person abides by them,
they're also there to help the other
person as well. No matter what emotion
tends to bubble up on the surface.
So,
when somebody's getting emotional in the
conversation and you're not really sure
what to do, what did we talk about?
Number one, you're going to maintain and
understand and identify your own
physical cues. What is happening to you
in your body? Your body will drive the
train. Number two, you're going to find
yourself grounding in that moment,
staying planted and present by using
phrases that help remind you to do that.
Like, there's space for this. Two things
can be true at the same time. I can be
mad and they can be sad and that's okay.
Three,
don't let yourself be walked over. If
you need to hold a boundary, do not let
their emotions all of a sudden become
your emotions. Don't let them just take
a stamp and stamp you with them and say,
"You have to also be upset if I'm
upset." I've seen that too sometimes in
people who
in relationships, they feel like, "I
just want you to argue with me. I want
you to be mad like I'm mad." They want
you to show some kind of emotion to see
if it's to feel something.
Be very careful with that because often
that's just a manipulation technique.
That's a technique that's they want to
self-soothe in some way because they are
dependent on your match
of emotion that may or may not be
healthy for you. I'm not saying that you
have to be somebody who's closed off and
you totally shut them out. That's not
what I'm saying whatsoever. At the same
time, I'm not saying that you have to be
someone of just because of they're mad,
well now you have to be mad. That's also
just as unhealthy. So, watch out for
that.
>> As any new debut author,
I, for good or for bad, have been
looking at reviews online cuz you want
to know are are people going to like the
book? That's the whole You get very
nervous. Are are Are you going to
deliver on the message? And the reviews
have been so kind and wonderful. And
there was one that hit me yesterday that
I randomly saw
that I wanted to share with you. It's
very short. I know you can listen to it.
Just bear with me. I know you can do it.
Listen.
You are not a target.
I was once told by my husband, "You are
an easy target and everyone knows it."
Time and again, I walked away defeated
even with my children. Jefferson showed
me what I lacked was communication
skills. From his social media, I started
applying these answers to difficult
situations.
Let me be clear. This is not a book of
his social media quips. That's what I
thought it would be. No. It is learning
to understand where people are and to
adequately communicate with them. It's
teaching to deepen relationships by way
of strong communication skills. You are
not a weak person for purchasing this
book.
You are strong and courageous for
recognizing there is a better way to
bridge a gap, create healthy boundaries
that work, to not get sucked down a
rabbit hole, to not think you've lost
your mind.
I highly recommend and I'm starting my
second read through. Kindle edition is
an easy read. Bless you, Jefferson, for
exhibiting love for people.
I I was just taken aback by I was
totally blown away by this.
I've no clue who this person is. In
fact, they didn't even leave their name.
It just says verified purchaser.
This is my point with this is I want you
to know where to go
in your mind
when conflict comes your way. You are
not a target.
And if you felt like you've been your
whole life, this is where it stops.
Rule number one in my book, there are
three rules. It's Rule number one, say
it with control. Number two, say it with
confidence. Number three, say it to
connect.
And the whole focus of Rule number one
is you can't say anything about what I
teach you, whether it's my phrases, my
quips, my little words, everything that
I I I can give you. None of it matters
if you do not say it
with control. If you do not first
regulate yourself.
So, we're going to talk about in this
episode what I want you to think about
when conflict comes your way.
Anytime that somebody says something
that you weren't expecting,
your body, naturally through its
biology, reacts.
People think that fight or flight is
something that has to happen when you
come with physical contact. No, that's
not true.
It happens every day in these little
micro moments. Even when somebody just
flatly disagrees with you. When somebody
disagrees with your opinion or they say
something you don't like or they call
you an ugly name, your body goes, "Hey
brain, I I didn't like that." And the
brain goes, "Give me a second. Yeah, no.
We definitely didn't like that." And it
naturally reacts. You have a scowl on
your face. You want to say something
back. You get heated. Your neck and jaw
get tense. All biological. All normal.
All natural. So, what do you do with
that?
Rule number one in my book is you use
your breath
as the first word that you say. And the
reason why is because it adds a distance
between what they say and how you
respond, which gives you time to
regulate yourself, to think of the quips
that I give you, and the sentences I
give you. And it also mutual The other
benefit is it allows the other person to
calm down theirs as well. Gives time for
that analytical side to take over.
Every day, there are little things that
tell your body, "I am threatened."
Somebody cuts in front of you in
traffic. Somebody merges. Somebody's
riding on your bumper. Your body goes,
"I am threatened." That's where road
rage comes from. "I feel threatened in
this environment." When you're talking
with your kids, when somebody um says
something to you that they disagree with
your opinion, they dismiss your idea.
You don't like that. Your body's saying,
"Hey, that feels threatening to me. I
want you to do something for me right
now." Now, if you're driving, don't
worry about it. If you're walking on the
treadmill, don't worry about it. You can
do it later. Do it in your head with me
right now. I want you to think of
behavior that somebody does that really
really upsets you. And we're going to
put a label on it. For example, maybe
it's disrespect.
Dismissive.
Condescending.
Belittling.
Rude. Whatever it is, make it yours.
What is a behavior that somebody
exhibits that really just just feels
like it sets you off, that just you just
explode when somebody does this to you.
You got it? You find that word.
Now, write it down.
And right next to it, I want you to
write "does not threaten me."
"Does not threaten me."
So, the sentence would be
"Dismissiveness does not threaten me.
Rude comments, back talk,
insults do not threaten me.
This is the mindset I want you to have
when this kind of stuff comes up in your
life. Why? Because it is telling your
body of Hey, when somebody raises their
voice, that doesn't threaten me.
When somebody calls me that, the way I'm
reacting and telling my body is
Hey, this does not threaten me.
That's what you're doing with your
breath in that moment. That's why we
give it time to tell your body what is
happening in front of me is not a
threat.
Right? It's this idea that
um you have you've seen the big animals
whether it's a lion or an elephant or
something they have like some
maybe a little dog or something. It they
just go, "What is this?" It's like a
little animal coming up to a big animal.
They're not threatened in any way.
That's the whole mindset here of Hey,
what you're doing is this isn't
threatening to me. I'm seeing right
through it. Cool?
I'm going to tell you a quick story
right now that
um I haven't I don't think I've ever
shared.
This was I don't know, maybe 3 weeks ago
or so.
And
where was I? I might have I think I was
in San Diego airport. I was in the San
Diego airport. It may have been San
Diego. Everything's blurring blending
together at this moment and it's early.
Give me a break.
Is
I got through security at TSA
and went and I was looking for my gate.
Looking for my gate and I kept following
the signs and then all of a sudden I was
outside of it outside of the the
security. The gate, the terminal, it
wasn't the terminal. The gate was
actually in a separate terminal. And I
just walked myself all the way through.
I'd already gone through security. I'd
already gone through all the the check
and the getting your stuff out and ready
and giving your ID.
I had I started walking out and I passed
this exit where it goes, you know, the
point of no return
where has a red line there at the
airport. And I walk out of it.
And all of a sudden, this is me by
myself and I look and I go
I say this out loud. I go, "Oh my gosh,
I got to
do this all over again."
Because I have to know I'm going further
down
where separate terminal is.
And I say, "Oh my gosh, I have I got to
do this all over again." And a voice
that
I had no clue where it was coming from.
Female voice goes,
"That's why you should read the sign,
sir."
And I'm trying to find who that is and I
turn and look.
And as I'm looking, she goes, "You have
no one to blame but yourself, sir.
That's why we have signs."
I don't know if you're feeling this,
just hearing it to me.
Just the way
the tone came across
was so condescending and unexpected and
unnecessary.
You ever had that?
"That's why we have signs, sir. You have
no one to blame but yourself."
And I remember
being just taken aback. Who who who are
you? And it was a TSA agent. Now, if
you're a TSA agent, I know not everybody
is
rough and can be terrible and I Hey, I'm
an attorney for crying out loud. Not all
attorneys are bad. There are some TSA
agents that are wonderful. There are
some people that are bad. We all have
bad apples in every profession. This one
right here,
this lady, she was middle-aged lady.
Uh just looked so smug when soon as she
said that.
And this is what my my body wanted
to come back with some really good
zingers in that moment. I wanted to say
a few things to her
because it was really rude. It was kind
of It was unnecessary.
And
this is what I did. Of course, I have to
practice what I preach, right?
I gave it
I looked at her for like 5 seconds
trying to figure out
is this
Did she say that?
And I just give it time.
And now she's sitting back and blinking
and looking at me. Her smile is gone.
And this is what I asked her. I said how
do you feel
when you say that kind of thing to
someone?
Does it give you joy?
That's what I said.
Like verbatim.
And immediately
she got red. Like um uh and just got red
in the face
and apologized right there.
I don't have to prompt anything. She
goes, I'm I'm I'm sorry I'm sorry, sir.
You're You're right. I That wasn't kind.
You're You're right, sir. I'm I'm sorry.
Yes, you you can find the terminal if
you go straight down. And now she was in
helping mode. Now she's in helping mode.
You can go right here and this is where
it's going to be. I was like, oh, well,
thank you very much. I appreciate that.
All right. You have a wonderful day.
You are not a target.
You are not somebody's punching bag. You
are not the outlet for somebody to
release all of their frustrations and
their angers and their smugness
on you.
These tools work. This is why I talk
about uh them. That's why I feel so
passionate about sharing these.
You had the choice right in that moment
when somebody says something ugly, when
they're the TSA agent in your life
how are you going to react? What are you
going to say to that person?
Are you going to allow them to just
press your remote control and manipulate
all your emotions? I had a choice. You
have a choice.
Is that going to ruin your day? I just
can't believe you'd say that. Excuse me,
is that what Excuse me, are you talking
to me?
I I
You see how it easily could go the other
way when you give in to that fight or
flight, when you don't use your breath,
when you don't regulate yourself.
If you do not say things with control,
it doesn't matter
what kind of tip I can give you. It's
not going to work. It ain't going to
work.
You have to say it with control.
You are not
a target.
I hope that
this is a good reminder for you,
wherever you are.
I can give you lots of tools and tips on
what to say. And we have different
podcast episodes on that, and I'm going
to continue to give you podcast episodes
on this.
And I want to make sure that you know
and you hear, and really the message is
very simple for today.
You are not a target.
When that happens, I want you to go to
your breath,
regulate yourself,
and then use the questions that I've
taught you. These are questions like,
"Did you mean Did you mean for that to
be rude?
Did you mean to insult me? Did you mean
for that to embarrass me?"
Or you give it time, and then you ask
somebody a question of intent. "How did
you expect me to react to that?" I could
have said that to her.
"How did you want me to respond to
that?"
"How does it make you feel?"
Imagine being the person
who would say that to someone.
These These ways of responding to rude
behavior
that is actually not a response. It's a
question.
You're not giving them matters of
substance. I'm not saying, "Let me You
You spit in my eye, let me spit back in
yours."
No, it is a reflection of their own
behavior and character.
And nine times out of 10, the other
person sees that because they because
you're giving them time to are seeing
It's like a the the blood the the red
Uh it's not blood. The red comes out of
their
system. You know, when somebody's seeing
red, you have to give them time for that
to go away.
Come back to normal. Come back. I know
that's not who you are. People are not
People are
far better
than we give them a chance to be. Why?
Because we know that in ourselves. So,
when you have the patience and the
discipline to get to that, you're going
to have a better communication and a
better relationship and a better life
because of that.
Cool?
All right. You are not a target. Hope
you have a wonderful day.
>> When I'm in a conversation that I feel
like I'm
um it's getting away from me. Let's say
that. That could be a sales negotiation.
It could be uh conversation with a
friend.
You name it.
Um
I feel like in my case most of the time
it's speeding up faster than I want it
to. You talk about this in rule one,
number six is control the pace.
And as I listen to you,
I mean, you're very cognizant even of
your pace and the way that you
communicate even on the show today and
even in your content you do. You're
actually a little faster when you do the
content from your car than you are right
now on the show. You're even a pace
slower today
than you are in your car. So, I watch
that like tonality and pacing.
Yeah, let's talk about that in a
conversation cuz with my when emotions
run high, often times for me, I feel
like the conversation is speeding up
where my my uh intellect is now not
quite as sharp as my emotions are
running, if that makes any sense.
So, what are strategies to control the
pace and what does that even mean?
>> Yeah, I love that you picked up on that.
The anytime you are getting that fight
or flight, and I know all of your
listeners highly educated, they know
fight or flight. Whenever you're getting
emotionally flooded like that, it is
that's why you're having trouble finding
your thoughts and connecting things. And
that's why the quicker you get, maybe
you've felt it where you you're either
nervous, same thing when you're really
mad, you might stammer and you might go
like no no no that that that's not in
your you're having trouble getting words
out. It's because you're just flooded.
Your emotions are there. Your logical
and analytical side is not. And so what
I teach everyone of my clients before
they go cross-examination and I'm
just offering them up to the wolves
is a constant reminder of you control
the pace, not them.
That means no matter how fast somebody's
peppering you with questions, the
conversation cannot happen any faster
than you respond.
So whenever they ask you a question and
you give a rapid-fire answer back, or
worse, you start to step over their
question cuz you already see where it's
going, bad things happen. You say things
you don't mean. You say things that are
not fully thought out. That's why even
in romantic relationships, all of a
sudden you blurt something out and you
go oh I I that's oh man, that's not what
I mean. And you you already knew as soon
as it came out of your mouth, you put
your foot in your mouth and you messed
up. It's because you weren't controlling
the pace. That means you need to slow
down your words and that you need to
leave space between what they said
and how you're going and when you're
going to respond. There's a difference
if you were to ask me
if if you said hey Jefferson, how was
your day? And I said good, it was real
good. I mean it was it was it was really
good, thanks. Versus hey Jefferson, how
was your day? And I said
It was good.
It was a good day.
Like you can just hear the difference in
which one listened to the question,
which one thought about the answer,
which one makes the other person feel
acknowledged or heard. Same thing with
that's why rule number one is say with
control. If you go down and let's say
you're at your work and all of a sudden
you go, "What's wrong? What happened?
What what what what's going on?" And you
all you're sensing and telling the
person is you're grasping for control
versus you come in,
take a breath, and then you're saying,
"All right.
What happened?" Give it to me. Like
people are looking like we said for
those emotional anchors. So, what I
teach is let your breath be the first
word that you say. That's how you set
the face of a conversation. So, where
your first word would be, put a breath
in its place. And what's that going to
do is keep your analytical side engaged
into where you do not allow yourself
emotionally to get emotionally flooded.
And the benefit second benefit is
neither does the other person because
now you are also injecting the time and
forcing them to slow down.
>> Would you agree that an an inability to
listen is probably the biggest mistake
people make when trying to communicate
effectively?
>> Yeah. And I mean listening is part of
communication. People think that
communicating is often what we send out.
It's not. It's It's really what
more about what we accept.
In my view, you think about it like if
you're going to write a letter,
like you you get a letter in the mail.
Like you can't read that letter and
write a response at the same time.
Well, that's what we do all the time.
Like every every day. We're not really
reading what they're saying. We're
either anticipating what they're going
to say or we don't care what they're
going to say. We're just focused on
writing the letter.
And
that inhibits our ability
to fully appreciate and fully understand
the other person.
The
it and it truly is a habit of listening.
I I I I to practice it all the time.
Mine is a little bit different because
it's part of my profession. So, when I
ask witnesses things,
I am listening because if I don't, they
could tell me something that's very good
for my case,
and I miss it because I'm writing down a
note, or I'm focused on what my next
question's going to be, just like you
were talking about.
But, the power to listen
not only shows that you're acknowledging
them, which makes them want to tell you
more,
it is
crucial
to exchange ideas.
>> And to building on on that idea then
of again of listening and and and being
thoughtful in a conversation,
>> Mhm.
>> what I found from podcasting, having
conversations with people, interviewing
people, having people
um you know, interview me,
one thing I notice a lot of people are
scared of is silence. Um they you know,
when when you ask a question or
somebody gives an answer, a lot of the
time people are scared to take
two, three, five seconds to process what
the other person said,
think consciously about what they're
going to say before they say it. A lot
of people I feel are are very uh
self-aware of how long it takes to
reply, and they want to look like they
boom, they're on it. They have the
perfect answer that they you know, that
they're super smart, they're they're
super attentive, but in reality to me,
when I see someone pause, maybe look up,
take a few seconds,
I almost value what they're going to say
to me even more than if they replied in
an instant.
>> Uh very good. Yeah, that's that's
exactly right. So, one of
the tips that I push when I go speaking
at different places
is when you let your breath be your
first word, That sounds kind of like
hippie dippy-ish, but it I mean it's
really a thing and I I it's what I tell
my clients, it's what I practice.
As if my breath is my first word, the
first thing that I say.
It makes a difference. And how would
it how it is perceived that I receive
that information. So, if you were to ask
me
uh I see that in your in your screen and
say, "Well, Jefferson, do you like the
Beatles?" All right. Okay, and if I just
immediately said, "Yeah."
Mhm. It it it just makes it seem like I
didn't really put any thought into it,
right? It was just this knee-jerk
reaction. Versus if you said,
"Jefferson, do you like the Beatles?"
And I went
"Yeah, I like the Beatles."
>> Yeah.
>> Like it it all of all of a sudden you're
like, "Oh, I'm okay. Yeah, he just he
just searched in his mind for something.
He really took the time." You see this a
lot in panels. Like if there's a panel
of four or five people, the person who
gets the question
takes a breath and takes their time
and then responds,
>> Mhm.
>> you have them waiting. Like they're just
>> Yeah.
>> You have a captive audience because
they're waiting for what you're going to
say. And it's makes makes it much more
impactful.
>> No, absolutely I I absolutely love that
and
I wonder then if we are dealing with
someone, you know, in that situation
where they're talking back at us, we
finish our thought and they're almost
into theirs before we could even finish
ours.
You know, they're cutting over us, they
can't wait to talk and you're thinking,
"They're not listening to me, they're
just
queuing up what they're going to say
next when I'm talking." How do we
deal with someone like that and turn
that conversation into an effective one
or an effective argument? How do we
combat when we can tell that someone's
not listening to us?
Well,
I mean, so things go through my head.
It's It's definitely contextual. The The
first thing that goes into my head is
why are we talking to this person?
But But let's say it's a It's a good
conversation and they
are certainly not interested in what you
have to say. Let's say it's somebody
who's pushing their point or wanting to
prove a point
and they're wanting you to
um
contribute in some way. A lot of the
time I The first thing I'll ask is
is this something you need me to agree
with?
I'll ask that. I'll say, "Is this
something you need me to to agree on?"
And typically they'll say, "No. No, I
don't I mean, I just needed to tell you
about you actually Well,
okay, because before I don't I'm not
telling them this, but beforehand
they're pushing. You know, they're
pushing pushing. Well, don't you think
Well, why don't you?" Like every time
you try to explain yourself, they're
cutting you off to try and corner you to
eventually just concede to their point.
Typically I get rid of that by the first
second question. I say, "Is this some
Hey, just let me Is this something that
you're needing me to
to for for us Is this something we're
needing to agree on?" That's what I'll
ask. "Is this something we need to agree
on?" When I ask that,
it totally changes the frame
of
them saying, "Actually no. I'm No, we're
just having a discussion." Great. Good.
Me, too.
If somebody is
pushing
interrupting you all the time, I I have
a kind of a
What's the word? Some some arrows in my
quiver of how I I handle that. And
usually I let them interrupt the first
time, but the second time
I will tell them calmly
say, "I I can't hear you
when you interrupt me."
So I'll say, "Hey, look
I lose I can't I mean, I I can't hear
you when you interrupt me."
And most of the time it's the same way
it works with my kids.
Like
when my daughter or my son have a very
whiny voice on something and they come
in whining, I'll say, "Uh-uh, I can't I
can't hear you. I can't hear you when
you talk like that." Voomp, all of a
sudden it changes.
>> Yeah.
>> They go right back to how they were.
It's just it's just trying to guide them
and if you want me to hear what you're
saying,
you're going to have to to talk in a
certain way.
>> Yeah, I mean that that sounds far more
effective than just actively tell, you
know, trying to shout louder than the
other person and I think that's when a a
conversation starts to become more of a
fight and ultimately when it becomes a
fight, no one's winning that argument.
>> No, nobody's winning that. Then it just
becomes
the then it just becomes worse. But it's
it's it's to really let people know that
so much of their communication in the
conflict
has to deal with
us. Like how how we
I can control how my conversations
generally go.
>> Mhm.
>> If somebody's being ugly to me, rude,
I'm in complete control.
Whether they have my emotions or not,
I'm going to allow them to to affect me.
And and a lot of that is your pace.
It I mean just like we talked about, I
slow everything down. My voice is going
to get lower. I'm going to go slower.
I'm more interested in why are they
saying this rather than thinking of the
next thing to say.
That that will um
that's good for all things in life, but
it certainly has helped me.
>> I was going to say as you were talking
about that then, um I was I was I was
thinking that you know, since we jumped
on this call, you have you know, your
your your pace has been quite slow,
you've you know, you've been in a deeper
voice and what I feel as though it's
doing to me is it's almost drawing me
closer to the screen and I'm I'm sort of
leaning in and and you know, I'm leaning
in further to what you've got to say and
it's you know, it's making me pay more
attention to you.
When you're talking to someone, are you
are is things like that something that
you're always conscious of or does this
is it just so second nature to you now
or do you know when to play on certain
things, when to use little tactics like
that?
>> Well, I'm just trying to I know it's
late over in your time so I'm just
trying to trying to make sure it's easy
for you to go to sleep.
>> of ASMR.
>> Yeah, you
you got I'm going to start tapping on
the microphone here in a second for you.
Um
it's it's it's second nature at this
point but it's also something very
intentional.
>> Yeah.
>> The way I and it's just natural with
anybody. The way you talk with your
friends
way you talk with your family
are very different than how you're going
to talk to me.
I talk to people in my video different
than I'm going to talk to
my family or my best friends. It's it's
all just
it's circumstantial to wherever you're
at. I mean context is
is is a big part of that. But I can tell
you when I'm trying to teach
when I'm trying to tell a story
I will absolutely slow it down because
it makes people more
interested
in every
word. I mean then they become like very
much like okay, what's what's is going
to happen versus if I'm just somebody
who's talking really fast all the time.
I'm just really so grateful to be here.
Thank you so much Louis like then it's
just you turn you tune it out. It's it's
too much.
>> It's sort of like
>> for the southerners like me.
>> It's sort of like when you listen to an
audio book on two times speed and you're
not taking anything in at all.
>> Mhm. No, and I did that before trying to
take my the bar exam for law school and
it was not a great idea. I did fine on
the exam but I I
yeah, I didn't absorb any of it.
I had a buddy of mine who recommended
that and that was a terrible that was a
terrible recommendation.
>> I wonder then what we're talking about
all these little techniques
um
a lot of people might you know they
might be listening to you talk about
these techniques like certain things
you'll say slow in your voice down they
might be thinking that's a little bit
sneaky. I wonder if anyone's ever used
that on me.
What would you say to the argument and I
have heard people pose this argument
that books and content on persuasion
on negotiation
um I've heard some people you know
describe them as
manipulative
um and really put a a negative spin on
it rather than that than a positive
spin. It's a subject I've always been
very interested in you know I I
years ago when I read um Never Split the
Difference by Chris Voss
>> Mhm.
>> it's something I've always been
interested in but I have heard people
take the opposite sort of stance on it.
What would you say to those people?
>> I would say
I hear you and I see where you're coming
from because there are certainly aspects
of
I I'm going to call it kind of the
darker
the the darker alleys back alleys of
communication and that are the people
who really push you know
sales techniques or different ways to
keep people on the phone get people to
say yes you're taking advantage of
people who might be what they call
more weak-minded you know there's
somebody who's just very susceptible to
going along with whatever you say.
That to me can be manipulative and
there's certainly people that manipulate
in conversation.
I would like to think that I am part of
the light in communication and that
means I I want to teach people to speak
with compassion and empathy and grace
for for the other person and
when I say like okay if I'm going to
slow my words make somebody feel more
invited more attentive I feel like those
are all things I want them
to feel cuz I I want them to know that
I'm paying attention. I think of like my
kids, if I need to calm my kids down
or if I need to tell them something
important,
that's exactly the kind of tone
that I'm I'm going to to take
because in some sense, if you're if
you're the leader in your life,
it's up to you to guide people
and shepherd people
into making them feel safe and together.
And that's that's what I try to push out
of these positive experiences and
interactions that you can actually
predict
uh based solely upon how you you
communicate. Are there people who would
use it to the others' disadvantage?
Absolutely. Those people I can't help
because they have bad intent and bad
motive. Now, that I can't fix.
But I I can certainly help you
learn to acknowledge somebody, to make
them feel more valued, to value
yourself, to feel like you can stand up
for yourself, lay more boundaries. All
these things that I think are much more
on the the healthier side of the
communication.
>> What about for people who struggle to
find their authentic voice?
>> Yeah.
You find that when people having a hard
time of just being who they are, I've
just want to represent themselves or you
feel like they're having to be somebody
that they're not.
>> Well, I feel like I mean, in my in my
own personal life, you know, I have
friends that
run the gamut on the spectrum of
self-awareness.
>> Yeah.
>> Um I have some friend I I personally I
would consider myself very self-aware.
>> Yeah.
>> Um whereas I have other friends that
seem to lack a degree of self-awareness,
you know, they kind of um
they seem very tethered to
like wrote behaviors, you know,
um
they don't seem to update their like
preferences very regularly.
Uh
Yeah, they're just they're just seems to
be like a lack of self-awareness and I
feel like there's like a
in between
you know, the external observer and who
they might actually really be
inside, there seems to be I guess what
sometimes referred to as like a block.
You
>> Yeah. I think that people are born with
a certain default of emotional
awareness.
My son is incredibly empathetic. I mean,
he can't he's kind of like me. When we
if there's a movie and there's a sad
part, we're both crying. I mean, we just
if something
we're just extremely sensitive to other
emotions. If something's happening, he's
thinking of well, how's that going to
affect his sister?
>> Mhm.
>> Now, his younger sister, who's a year
and a half younger, she could care less
about your emotions. She's not once
thinking about how anything's going to
affect you.
It's kind of that here's a good way of
thinking it.
Here in in
LA, traffic's a little bit different,
but in in Texas, like if you're driving
in the left lane where you're supposed
to go fast and people are backing up
behind you. Like me, oh my gosh, I'm
definitely going to move in the right
lane. I'm like, I'm so sorry. Let me get
out. I feel I feel that for you.
I've also been in cars with friends
where it don't bother them at all.
>> That's such a great example.
>> passing people and they're just driving
in the left lane. They have the whole
entire right lane. They could drive, but
they're not and they never they're just
never going to think about it.
And it's not their fault. It's just they
don't have a higher level default of
emotional they just it's it's not
intentional. They just don't have it.
And so, it is like how everybody has
different skill sets. You don't want me
doing your electrical work. You don't
want me building your birdhouse.
Um
but there are other people who are very
skilled at that and so, we all have just
different defaults kind of like a
soundboard in a studio. And I think that
somebody like in my world I and just in
yours I feel like I have more emotional
awareness. Others do not. That doesn't
mean it can't be learned. I think the
first step to learning is
understanding that there's a level of
curiosity you may not be looking for or
that you haven't asked for um to to
start there. But yes, to me it's the
left-hand left-hand lane drivers. I
can't stand them. Like how could you not
I guess I'll go to the right lane and
move around you.
>> Mhm. Oh my god, it's such a good such a
good
fantastic example of a complete lack of
emotional intelligence.
It's also like it's like the person
who's on the the piece of gym equipment
that you that you're kind of like
hovering around and they're like sitting
there on their phones.
>> Never going to look up. Exactly. But I'd
feel that. I'm like oh my gosh, let me
get up and let me wipe this off for you.
Like I can't.
>> Amen.
>> Yeah, I I just can't do that.
>> frustrating thing ever. Yeah. So how how
do we how do we Is it Is there a way to
cultivate greater emotional intelligence
or is it hardwired? Is it innate?
>> I think a lot of it is hardwired. I've
just that's your your default system and
the only way to work out anything is to
use it more.
So if
curiosity is a powerful
stimulus
um to where you can start wondering well
how would they be feeling? How could I
be doing that? It's asking those
external questions of the world around
you. How do you force somebody to do
that?
Who knows. Um
but what it does is inform you of when
I'm communicating with somebody, they
may not have the emotional awareness or
we you won't call it emotional
intelligence
to feel the same things that we do. Or
there's people who are
let's say neurodivergent. There are
people who they're they're never going
to
feel the emotions like you do. So you
have to communicate in a certain way.
All that means is there's nothing wrong
with that person. It just means you need
to adapt your style of
how you're communicating. You have to
say things to connect rather than how to
realize how how dare you instead of
taking this mindset of how dare you not
understand how I feel and getting
kind of all all in your own feels about
it, but instead of adapting your
communication.
>> Very interesting. Have you ever I'm
curious, have you ever studied like
improv comedy and um
>> I haven't studied it, but I love it.
It's so Yeah, it's so I mean they're
talented, especially the people who can
do crowd work. I mean it's just is such
a skill to be able to think that quickly
uh and land it. But yeah, I I love
comedy.
>> Is there a way Well,
I'm curious to know if there's a way to
to enhance that to become
you know, somebody who is perceived as
being wittier or sharper in that in that
sense, you know?
>> Yeah. I think the people that
are extremely funny are ones that
inside
I
what I know about is that a lot of times
inside there's some kind of internal
struggle or problem or drama that
they've they've had to
survive and they do that and not
surviving physically, but mentally,
emotionally and they do that by making
people laugh, by by getting that that
smile and that laugh and that it starts
probably at a very early age. Like my
son loves to tell jokes all the time and
they can be the most made up crazy joke
of Now, my daughter does it like hey,
knock knock say who there and she'll
just be like cat. Yeah, and it's she
thinks it's hilarious. Um and of course
that makes me laugh, but they understand
at a very young age that there are
certain things if they pull on that
string, they're going to get that
reaction. They want to make you laugh,
have a good time and that gives them
satisfaction.
I think that the um the people who are
experts at it, they're our masters at it
is so fun to watch because it's the
timing is so impressive. Like the the
comedic kind of pause of knowing
the right way to phrase a
that one sentence and it wouldn't have
been as funny if they didn't have that
pause if they didn't say it that one
way.
It's truly an art. If you if they just
come out with the line it wouldn't have
been any big deal but it's the delivery.
>> Timing, delivery, all that. I took
improv classes a couple years ago at I
want to say it was Groundlings in New
York. I could be wrong.
Um
It could have been Upright Citizens
Brigade. I don't I don't remember. It
was one of them but basically one of the
core tenants of improv comedy is the yes
and.
>> Yeah.
>> Are you familiar with that at all?
>> I am. Yeah.
Where it continues to roll the dialogue.
>> you don't want to shut down conversation
by using the yes and you're you're
basically accepting what's presented to
you conversationally and rather than
shutting it down with a no you say in a
way yes and to build on what was
presented.
>> Yeah and I I love that not only
because it's a great improv exercise but
you can use that even in negotiations in
business if somebody's complaining about
the price of something.
It's this is expensive. Yes and the
reason why it's expensive is because
there's X Y and Z and or yes it's one of
the most exclusive models. You're
building on it instead of if I said well
no I know it's not that expensive. I
mean if you look at and now they're
wanting to now I'm just showing them
disagreeing and now all they're going to
want to do is start to prove that yes it
is expensive. So the yes and is a much
better way of growing and it's also
it can be applied to a lot of different
communication of taking out the word
but. Like in apologies. I'm sorry
but I wouldn't have said that had you
not done this.
Using the but takes away from everything
or let's say
one of your best friends does something
and you go look hey I love you but you
drive me crazy.
The but kind of takes away from those
feelings or if I'm explaining something
and I'm saying I love everything that's
about I love this podcast and
everything. Um but
now it just kind of it de-minimizes what
I I just said previously. So but if you
say "and" it it takes it to a whole
'nother level. It's adding on. It's
adding on to that conversation.
>> Yeah, it's uh
whatever the opposite of entropy is, you
know? It's allowing something to like
flourish into new possibility.
>> Yeah, it it makes things uh grow and
that's that's where you want to take
conversation.
>> Amen.
>> Yeah.
>> When it's time for that difficult
conversation, number one, don't begin
with "How are you?"
"How are things?" Difficult
conversations are not the time for small
talk. The only thing that should come
out of your mouth is thank you for
making the time to talk with me. Number
two, follow that up with "I need your
help." "I need your help knowing how to
feel about this. I need your help
knowing what to do about this." When you
say "I need your help." it takes it from
opponents to teammates. And number
three, end with how you feel about the
conversation. "I feel better having
talked with you. I feel more settled
after discussing this." And the key is
you then end it with "So how about you?"
When you say "How about you?" you are
getting them to connect with you to say
"How do you feel about this
conversation? Do you feel better about
it or do we need to continue to talk?"
Now when I get questions about how to
have a difficult conversation, it
typically revolves around having to
deliver bad news. Meaning there is
something negative that you need to say
to someone and you know they are not
going to like it. You know they're going
to get upset. It's going to bother them.
It's going to ruin the mood. It's going
to ruin the the atmosphere or or
possibly ruin the relationship. Or you
see it with how to address a sensitive
topic. Maybe it's something that's been
laid heavy on your heart and you don't
know how to start. Or something that's
been bothering you and you know it's for
the best that you talk to this other
person about it and you just don't know
where to begin. You remove the difficult
from difficult conversations when you
break it down into bite-size pieces that
are going to connect you to that other
person. Now, typically in my life, where
I see difficult conversations is when I
have to deliver bad news to a client.
You know, not every case is perfect, and
not every client is a good client. And
not every case is a good case. The law
applies to the facts. So, sometimes you
have to tell them, "I'm sorry, but the
law doesn't allow this, or the law is
against you on this case."
So, that just is part of normal life,
and how you handle that conversation,
meaning not just what you say, but more
importantly, how you say it, can mean
the difference between making what comes
after the difficult conversation easier,
or just more difficult. Now, the
strategy does change slightly, depending
on whether you need to deliver bad news
or simply discuss a sensitive topic.
When it comes to strictly bad news, the
faster you get that bad news out, the
better the conversation is going to go.
For example, if you have to fire
someone, the first thing out of your
mouth should be, "I have bad news."
Or you need to say something that's hard
for them to hear, you tell them that.
"This is going to be hard to hear."
"This is going to be a difficult
conversation. This is not going to be
fun for us to talk about." You give them
a pause, and then you deliver the bad
news. In that moment, directness
is also kindness. All right? And when it
comes to sensitive topics, it's much
easier to follow steps one, two, and
three. Where you're going to say, "Thank
you for talking with me.
Um I need your help. I feel better about
this." So, let's go through a everyday
typical conversation where you need to
say something that's hard for them to
hear. So, let's assume you need to have
a difficult conversation with someone,
and let's make it about something they
said, a comment they made at a dinner
with friends last week. You've tried to
let it go,
but it's just not happening, and you
know that you need to talk with them
about it. If you're following rule
number one, what you're not going to do
is begin with, "So, how was this work?
How was this work today?" When you know
good and well that's not at all what you
really care about. Because what's worse
is when you make them talk about work,
and then you just drop the hammer
and say, "Oh, that's nice. Listen, you
remember what you said last week?"
That's a safe way to set this up for
failure. Instead, what you're going to
do is set aside time and say, "Hey, when
you have a moment, can we talk about
something?" Next, you're going to go to
rule number two. "I need your help." "I
need your help knowing how to feel about
a comment you made at dinner last week.
I've tried to let it go. I have dealt
with it and and just kind of simmered on
it in my mind, and I need your help
with it." Then have that conversation.
Tell them what they said. Tell them how
it made you feel. And that's the
difficult part is that you have to
express your own thoughts, and nobody
can do that for you. But what makes it
easier is when you lead with, "I need
your help." People love to be helpful.
They want to be helpful. Rather than
coming in and making them defensive and
and going into attack mode. When you can
say, "I need your help." It doesn't feel
like you're sitting on two separate
sides of the table, right? It makes you
feel like you've instead scooted up a
chair beside you and say, "Let's sit
together and look at this problem that's
on the table in front of us, and let's
work through it together." And when
you're able to have that conversation
and say what you need to say and get it
all out, or maybe you just need to hear
their perspective of what they meant by
their comment last week, it's going to
make
it better and bring you closer together
because it's the difficult conversations
that allow you the chance to dive deeper
into your relationship and grow and
build.
And then after you've had that
conversation, number three, you're going
to end with I feel X. I feel better.
I feel relieved. I feel more settled. I
feel better knowing your perspective or
where you were coming from in it. And
then you ask, "How about you? Or how are
you feeling? What do you think?" Get
that connection just a little bit closer
to to to wrap it up in a bow and say,
"Hey, we just went through something
that that was a little difficult. We
went through something that was not
easy. And then let's walk out of it hand
in hand. Let's walk out of it together."
Whatever it is, you have that meeting of
the minds to say, "I feel okay about
this. You feel okay about this? Got it?
Good. When we talk about difficult,
high-stress conflict, I'm I'm talking
about not just a little bitty everyday
arguments. I'm talking about something
that's on your plate that's coming up
right now and you go, "Jefferson, I
don't know how to handle this. I I don't
know what to do. I I'm afraid I'm going
to shut down. I'm afraid I'm going to
get nervous." I'm going to tell you
exactly what I tell every single one of
my clients. You ready? Number one, it is
not what you say. It is not anything to
do with your mouth. It has everything to
do with your
nervous system.
And the key here is instead of
absorbing,
you're observing.
I'm going to say it again. Instead of
absorbing,
you're observing. If you want to handle
conflict at a different level of
consciousness that you did not know you
could handle it,
it is going to be the key of not
absorbing what they say, but observing
what they say.
All right, say it with me. Say it with
me wherever you are. It's not absorbing,
it's observing. All right, what does
that mean?
I want you to think This is just coming
to me right now. I want you to think
you're in the grocery store and you have
your your cart with you and you're going
through and you or maybe maybe you're
somebody who likes a bag, you know, you
you you have a I'm I'm all for
environmentally friendly stuff, too,
though it's hard here in Texas.
And you have your cart.
And you just start putting things on the
shelf
that are grabbing things off the shelf
and putting it in your basket that you
you don't even want. Right? You don't
even want. And the things just start to
come in. You're like, "Yeah, I you know
what? I'm going to take their belittling
opinion of me. I'm going to put it in my
cart. You know what? I'm going to take
their side eye, put it in my cart. I'm
going to take that that disrespectful
tone and put that in my cart." And you
just keep going
all the way through, aisle by aisle. And
then you go to checkout.
Which is actually a very good word for
this. Yeah, you you you mentally check
out. And you know what checks in? Your
nervous system, your emotions. And they
just flood you in that moment in in a in
that point in time. You have absorbed,
you have taken on so many things that
there's nothing left for you.
You're not observing, you're not seeing
what's happening. You're just in it.
You're just in it, and you are helpless
to it. It is no longer you who controls
the emotions. The emotions are now
controlling you, and there's no telling
what you're going to say. There's no
There's no
nobody can guess what's going to come
out of your mouth or what's going to
happen because you're not there. You are
checked out. So, when I tell my clients,
"Hey, when you're in the chair and
somebody is the other attorney is asking
you questions, there's going to be a
time where all of a sudden you're
tempted to go in it
to to to go down the spiral and look
inside and look at yourself and feel
emotions and get heated because you're
going to start taking things personally.
You're going to start absorbing what
they're saying." No, no, no, no. If you
want to handle this the right way, the
proper way in conflict, you have to
start observing. What does that mean?
That means you're going to approach the
conversation at a different level of
consciousness that you have before. That
means instead of going, "How How could
he say that to me? Oh my gosh, I'm
And you start
holding your breath and you start
getting flustered and you get nervous
and maybe you tear up is because you're
not seeing it as huh
I wonder why he's asking me this. I
wonder why she's saying that. I wonder
where they're going with this.
Look for the intent behind the words.
The intent behind the words. When you
are observing what's happening in some
sense being an attached observer. I've
said this before where you it's like you
are sitting in a movie theater with your
popcorn and you're watching the
conversation take place and that puts
you in a different perspective of
looking at the person who's talking to
you.
And thinking I wonder why that character
is saying this. I wonder what the plot
is. I wonder what the narrative is. I I
wonder what scene is coming up next. And
you see how when you look at it that way
you have full control. You're now the
director, the producer, the screenwriter
of exactly what happens next and then
it's just action and you're able to be
in the state of mind of hey I'm
observing the conversation and from
there that gives you a chance to let
your body regulate because you're not in
it. You are seeing it. You're seeing the
conversation. Number two, what I teach
every one of my clients is something
that's at the forefront of my book The
Next Conversation Argue Less Talk More
and rule number one when I say say it
with control and that is let your breath
be the first word
that you say.
I've been talking a little fast here in
this podcast which is unlike me. I think
I
I'll tell you why. I drink
too much coffee this morning. Too much
coffee admittedly.
Usually I talk pretty slow, all right?
Can you hear how
just the way I'm talking now
and how I'm slowing down just a little
bit
might in a micro
percentage
also slow you down
a little bit.
Maybe, you know, the neural activity in
your brain is starting to slow down just
a little bit. Maybe you feel a little
bit more relaxed at me speaking a little
more slowly. When I put
breath
before my words,
it is making sure that I am regulating
myself.
And even more importantly, I am showing
you.
I'm showing you that I am regulated,
that I'm in control.
And what I'm about to say, I've chosen.
I've chosen those words.
Makes a very big difference. So, when I
teach my clients, hey, don't get wrapped
up. Don't try and step on somebody's
question. Don't try to interrupt them.
Let them get it out. And then you
observe the question. Observe the the
interaction. Take a breath.
And then choose what you want to say.
You are in complete control of the pace
of any conversation. Nobody can make you
say anything you don't want to say. And
nobody can make you say it at a time you
don't want to say it. That choice is
yours.
That choice is yours.
And I cannot tell you how many clients
I have seen come to find, accept, and
grow in their own power and their own
sense of value and worth of wow, I
I get to choose if I say anything. And
you know what? If I want to wait 30
seconds before I say something, I can do
that.
Uh it's it is a freeing feeling to know
mhm
No, I'm going to think about this. Let
me chew on this question for a second.
Just that alone.
The ability to say that
says, oh no, no, I'm I'm operating at a
different level you don't know about.
No, I'm I'm not who you thought I was. I
know exactly what I'm doing. I'm going
to choose my words
and I'm going to show you that what I'm
about to say is something that I
absolutely mean and I'm saying with
intention.
All right, you can you feel the
difference? So, what kind of breath are
we talking about? I've run through this
breath before. It's always good to do it
because it's something that is good for
me, too.
It's a conversational breath and what it
does, it's based on a physiological
sigh, which is a double
Well, that kind of sounded weird. Double
inhalation.
Double inhalation, so you're breathing
you're inhaling twice. All right, so you
ready with me? We're going to breathe
through your nose. Wherever you are,
just do it. Don't worry about it. People
might look at you, don't worry.
Ready? We're going to breathe in through
your nose about 2 to 3 seconds.
One more at the top.
And then let out through your nose.
My guess is you're starting to come down
a little bit. Maybe your shoulders
relaxed a little bit.
It's the feeling that mimics a sigh.
When you use that kind of breath, and I
promise you, you continue to do it while
I'm talking right now, you'll see that
you get really good at it. You can do it
anytime.
The most crucial part for me is when I
teach my clients to do it is before they
answer the question. Just take
2 seconds
or 1 second.
We like to say here in the South to just
say one Mississippi. In other words, in
in your head you're going to go
Mississippi.
Like, well, you you can use your own
name if you have a long name. You know,
just whatever it is, it's it's to get
you in the mindset of taking a beat, a
moment, take that breath, and choose
what you want to say. It is always going
to be better. And number three, the
third thing that I teach every single
one of my clients
is to use less words.
Say
less. Now, in the legal context, if my
witness
starts to give a very long answer, you
know what happens? Every Why do I say it
like that? He happens.
What happens is I guarantee them
that the opposing attorney is now going
to slice up
that long answer they just gave and turn
that into five more questions, 10 more
questions. The shorter the answer,
the stronger,
more
clear it is every single time. If I give
you an answer that is short and concise,
you can do nothing with it.
You can do nothing with it. Here the
difference. So, I might have a client
who I've trained and we we practice a
lot.
And when she might take a breath
and answer a question and go,
"No."
And that's it. That's the only answer.
What do What can the other attorney do?
Nothing. They can't do anything with it.
They can only go to their next question.
But, I've also had it, despite my
training
and teaching, where somebody goes,
"You know, I'm not sure. You know, that
it was just such a hectic day and you
know, I forgot to go pick up the eggs
and my and my dog was sick and you know,
he just
it just, you know, peanut butter messes
up his system and I I just find that
you're going and I'm going, "Oh my gosh,
what is happening?" So, that happens.
That happens cuz people are are human.
Right? So, we have to take a break and I
go, "What What are we doing? Come on.
Get back in it with me." So,
you see the difference in if somebody's
giving a very long answer,
some practical things happen.
One is
I'm get the witness is giving more
information than is needed.
Right? Unnecessary information, which
means the other person Let's put this in
everyday application. Everyday people
are going to get confused as to what the
answer is. They're going to fill in
their own assumptions of why you're not
answering it directly. They're going to
hear that there's just more words, which
just
automatically leads to the possibility
of more confusion and more
miscommunication. We don't want that. We
want short, concise. So, I like to say
it when I when I teach
is that if I ask you,
"Do you have the time?"
"Do you know what time it is?"
That means I'm going to ask you to stop
and ask that question in your mind, "Do
I know what time it is? What am I
asking?"
"Do you know what time it is?"
And if you give me the time, "Oh, it's
um 8:03."
That's the wrong answer.
That's the wrong answer. If I say, "Do
you know the time?" The answer is yes, I
do. It's that detailed. It is that
detailed because in my world it has to
be that detailed. You have to be. And in
everyday conversation, those high-stake,
high-emotion, just when everything is on
the the table, everything's on the line,
every little word of clarity matters
a great deal.
And I have to make sure that you're
prepared.
So, when you condense your words into
something that is very short, very
concise,
the longer of an answer you give, the
more opportunity there is for
miscommunication, more opportunity there
is for somebody to take your answer and
twist it. Here's an example. Have you
ever been in a text argument with
somebody? I have. I know you have.
And and
they just sent you something and you're
like, "Oh, really?" And you just start
texting on your phone, just going after
it. And you write a paragraph. I'm
talking you just you hit them so good
and it's perfect and you're it's it's
this is exactly how I feel.
And you send it and they send
a text that doesn't even address
anything that you said at all. Or maybe
they addressed one part that they could
defend and like, but they ignored all
the rest. It's that same principle.
You're giving someone way too much to
take and to twist. So, if you want to
handle high conflict like I teach every
one of my clients, you have to keep your
answers as short as possible. Answer
their question and only their question.
All right? Okay. Hey, look, you're
you're ready. You're ready. I know we we
maybe we're going to need to talk about
this. Let's go grab some coffee. Make
sure you get some snacks. Feel good.
We're about to go into this deposition
room together and you're going to do
awesome. I promise. What did we talk
about today? When it comes to
high-stakes conversation, number one,
observe, don't absorb.
Observe, don't absorb. Number two, use
your breath
as the first word that you say. Slow it
down and choose your words. Be
intentional with them. Make sure that
you are operating on your time frame,
not somebody else's. And number three,
say less. Shorten your answers. When you
give way too much, you allow the
opportunity for somebody to grab onto it
pieces and say things you didn't mean.
You're giving them more to twist. You're
giving them more to twist. It's like uh
giving somebody a long piece of rope.
They they're able to put a bunch of
knots in it. But if you just give them a
little bit of rope, it maybe it's not
even enough to do a
the tie their shoe with, right?
It's a big difference. You want to make
sure that you're very short and concise.
Man, my uh
examples today are all over the place.
We talked about the grocery store. We
talked about shoelaces. Man, what a
what a day. What an episode.
I am always proud of you and I hope you
use your words for good and for light
wherever you are. When someone is
quote-unquote attacking me or saying
nasty things about me that I don't
believe are true or maybe it's just I
don't like the way way they're saying it
and I don't want it to penetrate my
heart and my soul
and be reactive and defensive and
be angry and frustrated and all these
things.
>> When the when the when the brow goes
like this.
>> Yeah, exactly. One of the psychological
or therapeutic
uh strategies that I've learned
is to imagine
either a
a field an energetic field around me
that I can see it, but then it bounces
off.
>> Okay.
>> The words, the intention, the energy, it
comes and then boink, it just goes
around me and then
>> Right.
>> like water off a duck's back.
>> a Star Wars reference, but yes, that's
exactly right. Yeah.
>> Or what I'll do is I'll will
separate the ego from the self.
And I'll have the ego over here next to
me psychologically. And then image of
it, the ego of me here.
And I'll say, "Oh, they're just speaking
to the ego."
>> Yeah, no detachment.
>> They're just I like speaking over here.
They're not actually speaking to me.
They might be looking at me, but it's
just
redirecting right here. And oh, this
doesn't affect me.
>> Yeah, they're talking to that guy. Yeah.
>> And I saw um I think I saw I think it
was Salma Hayek one time talk about
this.
Um
and she was giving an example somewhere
online about how, you know, if someone
spoke to you really poorly in Spanish
and you don't speak Spanish, you're not
going to get defensive.
>> Right.
>> You're just going to be like, "Okay, I
have no clue what this crazy person is
saying to me."
Um okay, so just act like it's a
different language. At least it's
different ways of like
separating yourself from the
or the the potential pain.
What have you learned
to support yourself psychologically and
emotionally and spiritually
>> Yeah.
>> when this feeling of panic or stress
comes your way
or when potential attacks come your way
emotionally. So, very similar to yours,
I in my mind, I visually have a trash
can.
>> Oh, okay.
>> All right. And I can see it. It's one of
those big, huge gallon ones. It's the
black,
>> Sure.
>> shiny It's Yeah, you got it. Yeah.
>> And
I see what they're they're saying is
just a shoot. So, I can see the words
coming.
And I'm sipped.
>> Uh
>> Because the issue they're telling me is
not the real issue. And so, if I hear
something that's
uh offensive, that's not nice, I just
Okay, that's trash. Let me just I'm just
I In my mind, I grab it with my right
hand, lift up, and throw it out. Like
that's That's what I'll do with my with
my thoughts. And I'm sifting to where
if they might have led with something
that was snarky,
which our inclination is to grab onto
that and send it back to it. Yeah, send
it back and be like, "Oh, I just I got a
good one coming." Instead, Yeah, you got
it. Instead, if I throw that word away,
and I just trash it,
and then I found the one word that they
said at the very end, towards the end of
it, and that was That was the one
word. And then, if I focus on that word,
then it all starts to kind of
crumble. But that's I just imagine a
trash can.
>> What do you do when you cry in an
argument? Well, I'll tell you.
Absolutely
nothing. Don't you dare
for 1 second be ashamed or embarrassed
that you cry.
Do you feel embarrassed or ashamed when
your shoulders get tense, or your jaw
gets tight, or your eyebrows go down
because your body's not liking the
situation? Your body's reacting
naturally to what's happening. Do you
apologize then?
Of course, you don't. It's the same
thing for when you cry. It is just
biology. It's what happens. It is your
stress in liquid form. So, the next time
you feel tears starting to well up in
your eyes, this is what I want you to
do. Here's some three rules I'm going to
give you right now.
Number one,
don't ever apologize for it.
Don't say, "I'm I'm so sorry. I'm
I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. I'm crying
right now. Geez, I'm so sorry. I'm so
embarrassed." Absolutely not.
I will not allow that. I won't allow
that word.
You There's nothing to be ashamed of.
There's nothing you should be
apologizing for. It's how your body is
responding. Unless you're crying about a
topic that
you know, it's it's maybe it's funny.
Maybe it's something that it's not
appropriate to cry at, but
I can't even envision that.
Don't apologize for what your body is
naturally responding to in that moment.
Number two, don't even acknowledge them.
That means when you're in an argument
with someone and you're having a a
difficult conversation and it's a
difficult moment and you start to cry,
don't even acknowledge them. Just wipe
them away and keep on talking.
Wipe them away and keep on talking. If
you can grab a tissue, great. If not,
just wipe them away
and keep on talking. Don't acknowledge
them because if anything, it serves as a
distraction. It calls attention to it.
Number three, if you need to, label the
tears.
What I mean by that is if you feel
yourself crying, you can say, "These are
tired tears.
These are stressed tears. These are
tears that care. These are tears that um
are are
understanding the importance of this
moment." You find different words to
label the tears that doesn't feel like
you're just crying to cry. No, it's your
body responding to what is natural in
that moment. And let's talk for a second
about what crying is. When you cry, it
activates your parasympathetic nervous
system. It is the opposite of your fight
or flight mode. This is your rest,
digest, relaxation mode. What that means
is when you start to cry, your body is
helping you. It is trying to release
emotions. It is trying to soothe you.
Because in that moment, in that
argument, in that fight, your body's
telling you something. Your body's
saying, "Hey, your stress cup is too
full.
It's too full. It's about to overflow.
Let me take care of that for you." And
it does that in a way that you can start
to release emotions in the form of
liquid.
That's it. So, the higher the tension,
the higher the release. That's why it
makes sense when you cry to say, "I'm
These are just calm tears. My body's
calming down."
No, this is This is These are tears that
that care. I'm listening. Keep talking.
See what I mean? When you just say Say
to the other person, "Keep talking."
Even when you're crying, "Keep talking.
I'm listening. In other words, don't
worry about this. This is just my body
taking care of myself. See what I'm
doing right now? This is normal. This is
uh natural."
Let's Let's get rid of the stigma that
just because you're crying, it means
that you're trying to get attention.
Just because you're crying, it means
that you can't take the present moment.
No, it's your body fully prepared and
equipped to handle the conflict in front
of you. There's nothing wrong with it.
So, understand that when the tears come,
it is your body calming you down. It is
your body acting and processing exactly
the way it was made. And if you followed
my content for any amount of time,
you're going to recognize this phrase.
When you claim it,
you control it.
And I say it because it's applicable in
many different contexts, especially when
it comes to crying.
When you claim it, you control it. What
it means is when you say things out
loud, when you say how you're feeling
out loud,
you're able to control that emotion
better by acknowledging it out in the
open. So, instead of saying, "I'm sad."
and becoming the emotion, it's I can
tell I'm feeling sad. And now you
separated and distance yourself from
that feeling. And now you can process
it. Now you can deal with it. Now you
can communicate about it rather than
bottling it up all inside of you. And
that's why labeling is so important.
When you can say to the other person, "I
can tell that I'm frustrated." or "I can
tell these are These are tired tears.
Keep talking. I'm listening." then it's
no problem because it looks like you're
emotionally intelligent. It looks like
you're the person who's more in control
than rather "What's going on with you?
What's happening?" Oh, "I don't want to
talk about it." and you're just bottling
it up all inside. So, when you can claim
it, you control it and it makes you so
much more confident in that moment that
you're not worried about crying. You're
not worried about tears. Instead, you're
focused on communicating in the moment
in that present conversation. And I also
want to touch on what do you do when
someone else is crying in front of you
in an argument. So, you're in a
conversation one-on-one, what do you do
when the other person begins to cry?
Well, here's what you don't do. You
don't do Oh, "Okay, this again?"
You don't do that. You don't say, "Oh,
okay, fine. Got it. All right. Yes, you
got to cry. Fine." and act like it is
some inconvenience to you.
That's a problem.
That's That's That is toxic behavior
to act that way. That is immature,
emotionally immature, to say, "Oh, this
again? Okay. All right, I guess we'll
just take a time out." No.
We're not going to do that. If somebody
is crying in an argument, you don't
address it. Same thing for rule number
two for when you're the one crying,
don't address it. You just continue to
keep talking with them. That means you
don't break eye contact. That means you
don't say, "Oh, do you mean need a
minute? You need a minute?
Uh it's it's fine." No, you you don't
break any of that communication. You
still look at them like a normal person
and understand they're just talking. You
wouldn't do that say you need a break if
you see their shoulders get tense.
So, you're just going to say nothing and
continue to talk. Don't acknowledge it.
If you need anything at all, if you were
to do anything, it might be to if a
tissue's nearby, grab it and just hand
it to them and keep on talking or keep
on listening.
But, don't at all make them feel
ashamed. Don't at all try to make them
feel like they're an inconvenience to
the conversation
because they can't help it in any ways.
Now, I will say that there are some
because I I I understand this that this
is very true. Some people will use tears
as manipulation.
I mean, we get it from kids. My my
4-year-old, she uh I have a 6-year-old
son and a 4-year-old daughter. And don't
get me wrong, they both can turn on the
waterworks
like a faucet at any time and they can
quickly turn it off.
But, that's all the more reason why you
can't acknowledge it in that moment.
Now, if it's indication that they're
upset, it's different with kids. Let's
put this in terms of mature adults.
Hopefully, we're mature adults.
When they feel like they're crying, if
you feel at all that they're
manipulating the situation,
well, then that's all the more reason
for you not to acknowledge it. It's not
you being dismissive, it's you staying
in the lane of the conversation saying,
"No, I'm I'm focused on the words. I'm
not focused on how your body is reacting
in this moment." Whether it's genuine,
whether it's sincere or not, I'm focused
on the words and how we're going to
communicate this message back and forth.
If you enjoyed that clip and want to see
the rest of the conversation, you can
click right here. Or if you want to see
the latest episode of the Jefferson
Fisher podcast, click right here and
I'll meet you there.